hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 3rd 2020 what's going on
how are you
how are you everybody you feeling mellow
man
you know something i got the [ __ ] the
song in my head
anytime i watch the houston rockets and
i see james harden
every time i see him all i think is me
and mrs jones
we got a thing going on
that dude looks just like billy paul
and i know it's wrong every time i see
him
i mean i know i'm watching hoop but all
i'm thinking is me
mrs jones mrs joe mrs jones mrs
jones um
what is that song about is it about the
obvious
is the dude [ __ ] around you know
having an affair or as someone suggested
on the internet
he's talking about getting high i was
like oh [ __ ] is there like two meetings
mrs jones you know you got a jones
we're gonna meet the same time you know
tomorrow even though we know it's wrong
right um
anyway i gotta be honest with you i
actually have really been enjoying the
nba games with the virtual crowd
you know i think it's all right
the nba was like notorious for
constantly cutting to famous people
sitting on the side of the [ __ ]
in the crowd like who gives a [ __ ]
you know holy [ __ ] it's it's the guy
from uh the phantom
phantom of the opera look at him he
doesn't like that call
why do i give a [ __ ]
um i know there's a bunch of hockey
yesterday but somehow i ended up missing
it i missed all of it
and uh my bruins lost to the flyers
and some [ __ ] sent me a [ __ ] email
from philly because what else would they
be doing other than celebrating a
[ __ ] hockey win in august
[ __ ] douche even brought up the
eagles it's just like why would you do
that to a patriots fan
we won six you know
i don't understand bringing bringing up
the [ __ ] eagles what because you won
the last one we beat you that one but
you went one in one with us
you [ __ ] qb puked in the [ __ ]
huddle on the final goddamn drive
great you finally won a [ __ ] super
bowl
your first title in 60 years all right i
mean i guess if you want to talk [ __ ]
about it
um i actually literally have to remember
that loss that's how many [ __ ]
[ __ ] titles we won um and but this is
a big thing
how long will it be before the patriots
won another one what's gonna happen
first will the patriots win another
super bowl or the [ __ ] flyers and
they have like a 50-year drought all
right so was that was that like the
playoff game
bruins flyers overreaction b's in danger
of earning low
seed from round robin
uh
yeah who i i don't get i immediately go
to the playoffs here
the round robin flyers beat bruins in
nhl round robin game okay
flyers stay hot
they stayed hot okay stayed hot from
what this was like the first game back
you talking about the exhibition
whether you weigh their last few wins at
all that much or not the philadelphia
flyers remain on a roll the flyers beat
the bruins 4-1 in the first nhl
return to play round-robin game on
sunday
heading into the pandemic pause the
flyers saw a nine-game winning streak
end against the bruins being that the
flyers won on
sunday and also their exhibition
against the penguins this team has been
on quite an upper trend
jesus i mean that's a bit of a stretch
wouldn't you say
if you [ __ ] won eight games four
months ago and had a four month layoff
i'll tell you these guys just keep
rolling along you think the last 200
days they didn't play
um all right
i guess that's worthy of talking [ __ ] i
have no [ __ ] idea
i don't even know what's going on i mean
are you really gonna count this you're
gonna count this as a [ __ ] stanley
cup win if you win
this was like when the redskins won that
super bowl in the early 80s
when like some of their wins were like
with like scab players and [ __ ]
um i don't know i do know this is
as if there is a way to [ __ ] it up
and give somebody an unfair advantage
the nhl will figure out how to do it so
uh i don't know i have no idea how the
whole round-robin thing wins uh all i
know is we're one game back
and the flyers beat the bruins and
evidently they're on one hell of a
one-game roll
well good luck to you and the flyer sir
i don't give a [ __ ] i actually like the
flyers
and uh you know i can actually remember
when the bruins one of when when their
last cup you know it
that [ __ ] song uh joe bartnick sings
have you ever seen the flyers win the
cup
cup if you have you must be crying
because you know you're close to dying
have you ever seen the flyers win the
cup i mean
jesus christ [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
last time you won gerald ford was in
office
the big university of michigan star
um yeah so there you go congratulations
to them i think the celtics lost
we lost to the uh milwaukee bucks who
were looking great they were a number
one seed in the east
and we're wearing these uniforms like
what the [ __ ] are those
um it said cream city on them they had a
cream-colored jersey
and it said cream city i'm like what in
the [ __ ] is cream city
milwaukee's one of my favorite cities i
uh
i've been there a zillion times i love
it more and more
every single time and i love when people
say hey where would you live i said
milwaukee they always look at me like
i'm [ __ ] around
which because i'm like great the
secret's still not out all right
milwaukee cream city i looked it up
um and it has to do with the fact that
laverne and shirley
got so much dick during that um sitcom
no kidding
uh cream city it's because of the uh the
brick i guess
that cream-colored brick cream city is a
cream or
light yellow colored brick made from a
clay found around milwaukee
wisconsin in the uh the meno
menomonie river valley
it's so weird how we went in there and
just committed genocide against the
native americans just completely wiped
them out and then just
and then named [ __ ] after all of them um
on the western bank
of lake michigan these bricks were one
of the most common building materials
used in milwaukee during the mid
and late 19th century giving the city
the nickname cream city
and the bricks the name cream city
bricks
characteristics cream city bricks are
made from a red clay containing elevated
amounts of lime and sulfur this clay is
common in regions of wisconsin
especially near milwaukee when the
bricks are fired
they become creamy yellow in color
you know something dean delray keeps
showing me this [ __ ] he goes he's like
on instagram
following uh the this cheap houses
account and so many of them are like in
the midwest
and i will tell you something right now
there is nothing
more scary than a super old home in the
midwest
every single one of them looks like
[ __ ] ed gein is going to be coming
down the goddamn stairs
they're absolutely terrifying those old
houses with the [ __ ] wood and all
because they're always
empty you know in the middle of [ __ ]
knowing you're like jesus christ
how many crimes against humanity have
happened in this [ __ ] house
i saw one in the middle of kansas
there's a school for sale an entire
[ __ ] public school
you know big [ __ ] brick brick ass
building
enough to hold all those baby boomer
kids way back in the day in all the land
they want 25 grand for it so i was
texting some buddies of mine that make
movies i'm like you should [ __ ] buy
this thing
you'll have a location for the rest of
your career
this [ __ ] school could be a goddamn
office building
it could be a nut house it could be a
school
a precinct you could dress it up
anything you want it to be
and just [ __ ] become the tyler perry
of of the middle of [ __ ] nowhere in
kansas
you know none of them bid on it
you know i can only imagine the [ __ ]
problems that are in there
but uh but you got to see the picture
this thing they still have the old
[ __ ] desks in there when i say old
[ __ ] old like little house in the
prairie old
maybe not that far back but like desk
kids probably used to dive under when
they would take like um
they would do those practice the
russians are coming to bombus
um anyway so milwaukee known as cream
city because of the cream city brick
who the [ __ ] knew
um anyway so i was uh
last night my wife was watching this
this
freaking show about a serial killer
and uh i'm like i i don't i don't want
to watch this right before i go to bed
she's like no i just want to say it's
like really interesting it came in the
middle of it it was about the golden
state
uh i almost said warrior
the golden state uh killer
that guy you know where he just [ __ ]
raped and killed all these [ __ ] women
and
then that [ __ ] that came along
you know we you send your dna into the
internet
one of the dudes relatives sent it in
and it was a close enough match that
they knew it was part of the family and
they kind of narrowed it down to this
guy
they waited for him to have like a
fresca or some [ __ ] and they took the
can
out of the uh out of the garbage
and they had a 100 match and they
[ __ ] caught this guy
right so i'm watching this documentary
and i got to tell you something
there's something wrong
um with one of the people in that family
i just don't buy
anything that they say it
it seems like they're just saying what
they're supposed to be saying and i got
halfway through that and i'm like wait a
minute
can being a serial killer
is that like you know if you got like
music in your family
if you have a serial killer you know and
all of a sudden you know it skips a
generation but then
somebody just sits down and can play the
[ __ ] piano
you know does that happen with like
let me see let me look that up another
[ __ ] stupid thing on my goddamn
search engine
um
is being a serial killer
genetic all right i'm not the only dumb
one who asked this question
do all serial killers have a genetic
predisposed position no i mean
is it hereditary that's what i mean
no no one was dumb enough to ask this
uh
i don't know how to spell it her atr
red red a red
heredity hereditarial what is the is it
be oh my god
no it just refuses
can your genes make you kill and they
don't mean tight genes this is gene's g
with the g all right
that's [ __ ] hilarious i gotta wait
for a [ __ ] goddamn ford pickup ad
warning this product is not safe to
alternative cigarettes
it was a pickup truck all right um
the killer read his bible he drank
heavily it was
the fall night of 2006 when so-and-so
walked out of his rural trailer in
southeastern tennessee
carrying his 22-caliber hunting rifle
his estranged wife and his friend
and and i pulled up dropped up there was
upright eight times killing her he used
a knife
to cut her head open he then chased his
wife with the knife
and a machete
in the [ __ ]
there he told his fighting children come
tell your mama goodbye
because this last time they'd ever see
her miraculously his wife managed to
slip his grasp and escape is this a
movie
three years later in a county court the
dude admitted to the whole thing he said
he had snapped
i'm not proud of none of it he told the
truth
he convicted a felony murder he faced
the death penalty
to save his life his legal team took an
unusual approach never before
they said he had a generic variant on
his x chromosome the one that code all
right well
okay so you got a bad chromosome you got
to go
job is break down christian death
jesus [ __ ] christ i'm as i looked up
a [ __ ] recipe
i don't even care anymore you know
that's my ongoing complaint here anytime
you're like
hey what's a good pot roast recipe you
got to go through [ __ ] three pages of
you know growing up pot roast was always
one of the
the meals that just brought our family
together
the smell of it searing in the kitchen
my mother would always hum me and mrs
jones
and that's what we found out she was
[ __ ] a fat guy down the street that
she called her
her little side pot roast
anyways you're going to need two [ __ ]
sprigs of thyme
you got to read like a whole goddamn
soliloquy is that the [ __ ] word the
whole goddamn thing there
just to get to it i think you look up
how do you pour corn flakes on milk
you know cereal is really a dividing
issue in
the breakfast world i mean personally i
love it
but there's other people that just
cannot handle milk because they're
lactose intolerant
obviously this really affects the cereal
lobby
i remember when i was a kid my parents
wouldn't buy me tricks
so me and my little sister decided to
try to make our own
tricks um
[ __ ] scroll down 10 pages take your
favorite cereal pour it into a bowl
add milk um
anyway i've watched a lot of freaking tv
i didn't see the f1 race i knew there
was an f1 race but i also knew that
lewis hamilton was gonna win
and he did now he's like [ __ ] 30
points ahead
i did watch the last lap with that
high-pitched guy was just screaming
and lewis hamilton's car is falling
apart and he still wins the race
he just wins every [ __ ] race he
already has like a [ __ ]
30 40 point lead i mean he's just too
goddamn good
the guy won the race on like three tires
like [ __ ] stroke a race
that shit's only supposed to happen in
the goddamn uh
in in the in the movies i actually kind
of stopped watching f1 because i was
starting to have this irrational hatred
of lewis hamilton
simply because he was so [ __ ] good
and was winning
he was so good he was making it boring
then i'm like why am i why am i
bothered by this guy dominating like
this
it's like well you know because i turned
on to see a race i want to see racing
i want to see passing i want to see
excitement
i don't want to see and lewis hamilton
is the first one out of the first turn
and we all know that the race is already
over even though there's 70 laps left
um i will tell you a great documentary
you got to watch you got to watch the
robert foster documentary
he's this legendary uh record producer
who just has like this gift where he can
you know
hear a hit make a hit and all of that
but i'm gonna tell you something man
i you watch this documentary this dude
is the closest thing to like
if like ron burgundy was a was a real
person
i mean the guy's [ __ ] ego is like
i don't even know where to begin the
stories that he told about himself
none of them had a left turn every one
of them was i had to do this
and i didn't have enough time and i
[ __ ] crushed it
[Laughter]
he's like when i was a kid my mother
played on the piano
and i immediately said that's an e and
she was like what
and i was like that's an e and she was
like
oh my god he has perfect pitch
he was telling these stories about
himself then he told this weird story
i like his [ __ ] he had like four or
five sisters and his mother
every morning would feed them like soggy
[ __ ] corn flakes
and then make him bacon and eggs with
toast every morning you're like oh
there it is you were the little prince
and all the other ones were like
scrubbing the floor with toothbrushes
and at no point was he sort of alluding
like you know i was [ __ ] up she was
there playing
favorites like that
the best part right is all the people
around him
who are just sitting there talking about
how [ __ ] amazing he is
you know none of them questioning the
guy's ego this one [ __ ] poor woman
i don't know what he had on her but
she's just like you know it's about time
you did broadway i mean she's literally
pointing to a fake watch in her wrist
he's sitting there going like [ __ ] i
don't know i can't even get it
it was like and then barbra streisand
told me she wanted an
album that was all synthesizers no drums
no bass no french horn no bassoon
and i gotta tell you
i killed it
this guy goes like he's the greatest
keyboard player i've ever heard
and i've played with herbie he's talking
herbie hancock
right and then they cut to david foster
and he's working with chicago
and he literally takes the horn section
out of chicago he
de-balls the [ __ ] band he's better
than herbie hancock and then you're
watching peter cetera singing one of the
songs
i am a man who will fight for
your runner it's like
that's better than bow bow bow baby get
the [ __ ] out of here
let me incomplete with miles davis
these [ __ ] guys writing it and i i
will always love you
um anyways check it out if
if you get a chance check it out i mean
it is amazing what the guy has done but
jesus christ what a [ __ ] ego on that
guy
and then oh these [ __ ] kids come on
and evidently this guy was like one of
the worst fathers ever
as far as just like his kids even his
kids were sticking up for him though
maybe it's true he's going yeah i was
born and then he left like six seven
months later but you know
he's still a great dad he did the best
he could
it's really bizarre um all you need to
do is just see the picture that
that is promoting the documentary it's
him with like
72 oscars i mean sorry uh what do you
call those [ __ ]
music ones grammys
and he's just sitting there next to him
like yeah
i'm this [ __ ] good
i got a great idea for a promo everybody
how about i just sit here with all my
trophies
um but evidently he wants an oscar
because he wants to be an egot
that's another thing he lists all his
trophies and goes and i still feel my
trophy case is a little light
oh it's just like gee why don't you just
tell people that it's time for the gun
show
um anyways i think the only reason why
chicago didn't get more [ __ ] for the
songs that they did in the 80s was
because phil collins was doing all that
other stuff
phil collins for some reason became like
the bee gees there's always one band
that just takes a [ __ ] pounding
you know i don't know who it is this
decade or last decade i remember two
decades ago it was like nickelback
and then the decade before that who took
the pounding
[Music]
um
one of those rap metal bands probably
i got no idea there's always just
somebody just out of nowhere just all of
a sudden
everybody was buying their albums then
out of nowhere they just get a ton of
[ __ ]
so in the 80s it was like phil collins
maybe millie vanilli
um in the 70s well i can't say that i
think in the 90s it's the decade after
when people then look back
going like hey man that band's [ __ ]
lame it's like oh the one that we all
listen to
now we're all trying to walk away from
the style man
um sorry i have no idea what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about here
it's 22 minutes in maybe it's time maybe
it's time
to do a little bit of [ __ ] reads here
people i'm actually i'm trying to put
together
a uh
a [ __ ] uh stand-up tour here
because at some point i also have to go
out i gotta earn some [ __ ] money here
you know
got a house to pay for i'm trying to
figure out how i can do it
like the show has to go down where
nobody at the show
gets uh gets coveted obviously so that's
the part that we're working on oh it's
it's easy to protect the person on stage
you know but it's the people in the
crowd there
um like how do you work it if you get
one of these stubborn [ __ ]
people that refuses to wear a [ __ ]
mask
or the ones that walk around wearing the
mask and have it underneath their nose
what do you do with that person
um i don't know but the mass shaming is
getting crazy i saw this one
this video on instagram where these two
what sounded like young people were just
yelling at this [ __ ]
look the woman looked like a retired
witch this old white lady with like
white hair and [ __ ]
they're just yelling and it's like we
you [ __ ] leave her alone she's
somebody's grand
parent you know what i mean she has it
she's gonna [ __ ] die from it
and they're just hounding her screaming
at us and she comes over and she [ __ ]
coughs on him
which is inevitable it's like how much
[ __ ] can you give your waitress before
you know she's gonna spit in your
[ __ ] tee
you gotta go easy and they're [ __ ]
sitting there yelling at him then when
somebody coughs something like
call the police that's it call the
police
and then they both get [ __ ] charged
with being docious
i hope they put them in the same goddamn
cell
um anyway
what else i'm sorry i'm in a [ __ ] up
mood because i saw yet another
thing happened to a comedian where it's
just like
it's accusations and then people just
like sign off on it
before the person can even defend
themselves now i mean
you're just sitting there going like
were you there
aren't you like me like i have no idea
if this is true i have no idea if this
happened i don't know if it didn't
happen
i just know there's some people saying
something happened
and then my favorite my favorite [ __ ]
thing
is the bitter ass comic you know what i
mean
who uses that situation
as an excuse to air their personal
feelings about that comedian's act
i mean how [ __ ] low can you go
jesus christ the [ __ ] somebody's
laying on the side of the [ __ ] road
for all you know could be it's innocent
and you take
the time to be like you know it's always
like
you know i can't believe this [ __ ]
guy blah blah blah
blah the [ __ ] they just been accused
about and then there's some sort of
criticism
about the act i thought his biggest
crime was that he was called the
comedian
it's just like wow wow
what kind of [ __ ] person are you what
kind of [ __ ] person are you that you
take a [ __ ] that you'd use
you know people are trying to suggest
it's a sexual assault happened here
and you're gonna use that platform so
you can get out your [ __ ] bitterness
about where your [ __ ] career is act
unbelievable unfucking believable so
this person actually made a video
and in the video you know the part that
i love
is they're [ __ ] sitting there saying
how the their people around them were
advising him
to not say anything just let the news
cycle pass
it's just like
it i don't understand why the accused
person
can't defend themselves it's [ __ ]
nuts and i don't get how all these
people are signing off like
yeah this makes sense this seems like
the right solution
for this so i'm actually you know
happy the person ignored and actually
made a video and hopefully people will
start doing that again and due process
will return and hopefully this time
due process will actually work for
victims
if they were actually victims i mean
isn't that the logical way you should be
looking at this
rather than just being like somebody
said something happened
all right that's it that means it
happened hey i'd like to defend myself
no
you shut the [ __ ] up all i need to hear
is an accusation i don't need any
[ __ ] evidence whatsoever
um blows my [ __ ] mind i understand
regular [ __ ] people they're bored
right now they're in the middle of a
[ __ ] pandemic so yeah throw someone
to the lines for my [ __ ]
entertainment but to see fellow
comedians
jumping on this [ __ ] um and you want to
be like oh so evidently you were there
you know or did some i don't know what
[ __ ] evidence you have that makes you
that [ __ ] but what it really comes down
to i then [ __ ] see is it always comes
down to
they then they don't like him as a
comedian
um jesus what a complete [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] person
that you would do that to somebody you
know not saying whether the person
accused is innocent or guilty because i
have no [ __ ] idea
um you know that's why you have a
[ __ ] trial
all right let's do a little bit of reads
here let's do some reads
let's do some reads all right helix
everybody alex
all right not being able to sleep
because of today's politics
your love life and all the other drama
mention shitty sleeping conditions on
the road you've had to deal with oh
jesus christ
on the road i've had beds i've been
afraid to climb into and i just you just
do it you got to make it your own
it's got to get your dna on it you know
i'll tell you a bad one is when i used
to stay in those [ __ ] motels where
the doors opened up out into the parking
lot
and every time a car would pull up i'd
see the headlights underneath the
[ __ ]
underneath the goddamn door and you're
just going like just one
good [ __ ] kick and that door is gonna
come flying open and i am in here
without a weapon
i'll tell you i understand people buying
guns when you [ __ ] stay in a goddamn
motel that opens up into the
to the goddamn uh [ __ ] parking lot
um anyways helix sleep makes
personalized mattresses made right here
in america
that's good we make weed we make
mattresses
and ships straight to your door with a
free no contract
uh delivery free returns at a hundred
nights sleep trial
gross uh to choose a mattress helix
helix
made a quick quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body types
and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress for you
um if you like a mattress that's really
soft or
firm ladies uh you sleep on your side or
your back or your stomach you sleep
really hot with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's
unique tastes i love helix but you don't
need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress
pick of 2020. they did it again by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life life life
life life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights gross
risk-free they'll even pick it up gross
and give you a full refund if you don't
love it
but you will right now helix is offering
up to 200 off mattress orders for our
listeners
get up to 200 off at helixsleep.com
oh [ __ ] look who it is whoop whoop
everybody
whoop there it is sorry uh if you're
going to mention the pga tour
this is how we have to technically
phrase it whoop
has been all over the news lately after
the pga tour proceeded
or procured 1 000 straps for its golfers
caddies
and staff to help everyone at
tournaments stay safe throughout this
pandemic uh whoop has been
using respiratory rate to help members
detect potential signs of illness before
other symptoms develop
thank god thank god for science
whoop can help anyone perform better
whether it's preparing for a golf match
race meeting etc whoop can plan out your
day and make even
smarter life decisions to help you feel
better than ever
the whoop journal and monthly
performance assessment allows you to
track the decisions you make during the
day and actually see what impact those
choices have on your recovery sleep and
strain
[Music]
tracks all four stages of sleep slow
wave rem
light and awake and can tell you how
much sleep you've gotten down to the
minute
their sleep tracking has also officially
received third
party validations strain coach is
a feature that allows you to plan your
workday to hit your target
exertion level this is really
fascinating i almost want to use this
for something that i've i've been doing
with my drumming
uh hang on a second plan the workout
that your body is truly ready for
check your progress in real time and
finish your workout
when whoop has let you know you've
pushed your body hard enough
the key to whoop is that you wear it all
day long and never miss a beat whoop has
a really smart charging system
where the battery pack slides right over
the top of the strap so you can never
oh they mean like one of those wrist
[ __ ] i thought i thought when they
said the strap
i thought they met the strap on the golf
bag
like that's what you touched the most
and somehow they came up with a
germ-free one
oh this is like a fitbit you won't ever
have to worry about losing a night's
sleep
or missing a workout whoop is offering
15 off when you use the code burr at
checkout go to woop.com w-h-o-o-p
dot com and enter the code uh burp
b-u-r-r
to save 15 off sleep better recover
faster and train smarter with whoop
today
that is amazing that they have that
technology where you can really break
down
like i mean like you're turning yourself
into a friggin race car
i mean as long as they don't share it
with anybody i'm sure they won't
um i've been doing this thing with uh
drumming as i've i've been you know
the drum lick that has eluded me forever
and i've really
realized it was be it's it's the the
bonham good times bad times
thing that i've been talking about
forever it's just alluded to me because
of my practice was flawed i would try
i didn't have the technique and then i
would try to go
too fast too quickly and then i would
get discouraged and i would move on to
something else
and then i would come back and i would
do the exact same thing
that you know led to me not being
successful
the previous 59 000 times so
what i've been doing is before i play
drums
is i stretch for like 20 minutes because
i'm [ __ ] old
do a really good long stretch i get
totally relaxed and then i go in the
drum room and i just start playing and i
play as slow
as possible not as possible just like
really slow
and just slowly warm up
my my hands my feet legs and the whole
thing
and then when i go to do the good times
bad times thing i just warm up
super [ __ ] slow and just
gradually increase it and
i don't have any goal other than
i am going to practice this lick really
slow
and then i'm gonna ramp it up to where
it's comfortable
and then push myself a little bit and
that could be a little bit further than
what i did
yesterday or it could be a little bit
slower i don't care
i'm just gonna [ __ ] do this so i've
been doing that
and when i play it's like i'm gonna be
really
relaxed so there's like these two bars
that i play
when you come out of the solo before he
plays that lick
[ __ ] ten times in a row back to back
towards the end of the song and what i
say to myself and those two bars is i
just say
as i'm coming up to it as i just say
i just tell myself to relax
and who gives a [ __ ] you know
if i pull it off just make sure you get
that first one
and what's been happening is is i'm
actually
staying relaxed and then when i get that
first one and i
i come into it relaxed and and i get
that first one off
i just sort of lock into it and now all
of a sudden
you know the speed is coming and i've
been able to play it
um last night i got the the 16th note
triplet three times in a row
at 90 bpms and the song is 95. it's the
closest i've ever got i can't play it 10
times a row but i did play
the ten times in a row lick um
at 80 bpms comfortably and
i almost played it at 85 before it sort
of crapped out so now i'm just like
great so then i went back down to like
75.
and i just sort of played the whole song
jumped around the song i
liked the sheet music and just sort of
locked that in that that just feels
relaxed
and regular and then i ran back up to 80
which was way easier at that point and i
just sort of played that
and then i stopped
and uh i don't know if just that's been
working for me
because uh i've i've i think pretty much
everything
from paradiddles to everything i never
fully got up to speed
because i am really [ __ ] impatient
and i sit down scatterbrained
and there's like 50 [ __ ] things i
want to learn how to do so i do all 50
things
for like 18 seconds each and
and nothing really gets better and it
all gets [ __ ] it's all sloppy
you know then it sounds like [ __ ] so
i've had to figure that out about my
brain
and now when i sit down i have to have
my brain like totally clear and i really
have to just be like nope we're just
working on this
we're just working on this and then i
apply a bunch of [ __ ]
that i learned from dave elich back in
the day when a week i could actually go
get a [ __ ] lesson you know face to
face
is um i've just
i just applied all of this stuff as far
as like relaxing
how i'm sitting and
[Music]
i don't know i think if you go beyond
that if you have a good teacher if you
really sit there and figure out how your
brain works and what you're doing
to contribute to not being successful
um i mean i came in last night you know
i was like
flying i was like i can't [ __ ]
believe i did all this that's the
fastest i ever played that
um so
that's that's going to be my new my new
approach
uh when i'm downstairs i always get
nervous when i start talking about drums
for too [ __ ] long that people can be
like all right bill we get it we don't
all [ __ ] play drums
all right stamps.com everybody uh as we
slowly adjust to the new
normal is this how it's gonna be forever
we still need to be smart about how we
do business luckily there's stamps.com
to make things easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months yeah you don't have to go
to the post office and risk you risk
getting infected or passing along the
disease
they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office
all from their own computers stamps.com
offers ups services with discounts up to
62 percent
and no residential surcharges by the way
why can't everybody just go to work with
the mask now
and they just do that thing where they
take your temperature i'm not saying
that it's totally foolproof but like
you know just to give people a financial
[ __ ] break here
um anyway you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over seven years now and if you
haven't tried it
what are you waiting for stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need
right to your own computer and you're
the comfort of your own home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices an online seller
shipping out products or just working
from home and need to to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
once your mail is ready just leave it to
your mail carrier
schedule a pickup or drop it in the
mailbox it's just that simple
um and like i said with stamps.com you
get this great discounts
two five cents off every stamp and up to
62 percent off
usps and ups shipping rates
five cents off every stamp i mean that's
gonna add up people every 20 things you
send out you saved a dollar
right five dollar foot long right you
send out 100 [ __ ] packages all of a
sudden you got yourself a free sandwich
right now our my listeners are getting
uh get a special offer that includes a
four week
uh trial plus free postage right now
uh my listeners well i just read that
uh right now my listeners get a special
off that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in bur
burr that's stamps.com enter bur
all right now it's time now it's time to
say goodbye
did i read all the ones i guess i did i
guess i did
i got to get into hockey i'm actually
psyched that philly fan
wrote in that [ __ ] you know get me going
here
um guest in own home all right here we
go
hey bill i hear you on the wife feeling
like you're a guest in your own home
i'm an airline pilot and have been home
way more
than ever which i took is a good thing
but apparently i'm screwing up her in
the kid's routine
i just keep biting my tongue thinking
what the routine would be like if
someone wasn't off working
to pay for all this [ __ ]
rant over love the podcast stand up and
f is for family thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
yeah i mean you got
you need to understand her and she needs
to understand you
because like um i always see like
with professional uh
sports athletes right professional
athletes um
they provide an amazing obviously
lifestyle for everybody to be living but
then
like they're not home a lot so what
happens is
everybody gets into this [ __ ] groove
that doesn't involve you and then all of
a sudden you come home
and then yeah you do disrupt it so uh
yeah so there's that weird thing that
she is right that you are disrupting the
routine but
you know it would be nice if she also
acknowledged that you're paying
for the routine um but that's not how it
works
you know i found that when you when you
actually make a good point
with the woman that automatically means
that you just somehow
threw something in their face rather
than you brought up a point to defend
your own position
well you don't need to throw it in my
face i didn't throw anything i just said
it
trying to give you a little bit of
perspective it sounds to me
like you on some level think what i just
made was a great point
and you can't really refute it so now
what you're going to do is act like i
was
that somehow by me bringing up a great
point
to shine a light on my position is
somehow being rude to you
am i supposed to just sit here and be a
[ __ ] punching bag
um that is [ __ ] amazing that you're a
[ __ ] airline pilot so you probably
have like 300 people's lives in the palm
of your hand for the better part of
anywhere from three to six hours
and you have to handle that you have to
fly instrument
every [ __ ] flight right anything
above oh my god i already forget
anything above 18 000 feet i think
you'll automatically fly instrument
um i don't know but i'm back into flying
baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm flying twice a week and i wish i was
flying three times a week
my auto rotations are getting really
really good last time i flew
um i was really working on that last
part of it where i don't bring the nose
up
you know and make my rpms go up and i
lose my air speed to stay
level and just wait to do that that
flare
um once i get that down once i get that
down and then there's the last little
part just leveling out
and pulling power right before you
settle down onto the ground
um i had a did a great flight went out
to
camarillo airport um
the last time and i used this for flight
app that i literally sat down
and i watched this guy give like an
hour and seven minute instructional
thing on and now i i get it
and one of my favorite things about the
app is they actually have a 3d picture
of whatever airport so if you're not
familiar with the airport you can
actually look
and get up a 3d visual of what the
approach is going to look like
you combine that with the map of the
airport and then you you take an airport
that you were totally unfamiliar with
um i would never say that i'm familiar
now because i hadn't gone to it before
or hadn't gone to it in a while but
you're just so much you have this
picture in your head
you got all the uh taxiways and
everything you know
the runways and you got the whole
[ __ ] layout
and um i actually feel confident now
because that's one of the ones that's
really busy a lot and uh
i would get anxiety whenever i come in
there because you want to talk quickly
you don't want to step on anybody and
you don't
have to have the tower repeat anything
to you
so what i would normally do is just
transition which means i would just ask
to fly through their airspace which is
the easiest thing
but this past time i actually did some
pad work at the north pad that they
they have there or whatever and um
i had a great time although i got a
little frustrated some stuff what i'm
really learning is it's just like
drumming
is that you know i've really been like
holding on too tight with the controls
is you want to be like
the looser you are the more
information you can take in as far as
like what the helicopter's telling you
um most importantly which way the wind's
coming from
and i started to do that last time
because i had a couple you know i came
back it was
just like the first times i soloed where
i would go into the downwind and all of
a sudden the [ __ ]
low rpm horn would come on and i
think oh my god i'm having a [ __ ]
engine failure and it was just because i
was gripping the throttle too tightly
and i was overriding the governor and uh
i did that a couple times so i really
had to think about it but like
all my instructors have always said
you're going to be like with your feet
on the pedals to have all your weight
like on your heels like
super light and when you're pushing down
either your left or your right foot the
other foot is not even touching
the um it's barely touching i should say
the other pedal and um
i don't know that you you just want to
like because
i don't know what it is like
i don't know the more nervous you are
the less comfortable you are the more
rusty you are just the tighter you're
holding on to that thing
and then exactly what you don't want to
do which is fight the thing ends up
[ __ ] happening and it's the same
thing as like
playing some drum lick that's super
[ __ ] fast is if you tense up
it just all goes to [ __ ] so um
i don't know like i said i'm flying a
couple times a week i'd like to fly
three three would be [ __ ] huge for me
as far as
um you know because it always ends up
being like a three four day layoff
as opposed to like if i flew every other
day how good i could get
would be awesome so um but i also have
responsibilities here at home so we'll
figure it out anyway
i'm babbling now babbling on all right
let's read the next one here all right
aging out
oh sorry guest in in own home
hey bill i hear you on the wife oh no
sorry i already read that one okay aging
out of moto gp
uh heli hey hey there billy
uh berquez instead of marquez love your
stuff yadda yadda
what makes rossie's age impressive is
okay so valentino rossi is like 41 years
old and he's still
competing at uh the highest level in
motorcycle racing in the world
and he gets on the podium still like
once a season or so
um so i was like well you know it is the
machine and all that
what is what is it about his age why is
it so hard to keep
riding at his age does your body break
down
um taking all those g's obviously
falling off the bike and [ __ ] so anyways
the person says hey
the usual stuff that a lot of that this
is what makes it impressive
the usual stuff that a lot of athletes
go through injuries that build up over
the years
census not being as sharp as they used
to be i didn't think of that
getting tired of the travel in the media
circus but also
b since he started riding in the lower
classes in 1996 it's incredible
uh there have been endless changes to
the rules
regarding tires electronics engine sizes
and tracks coming and going from the
calendar yeah that's like a belichick
thing like how you're successful for
that long because usually you win a
couple super bowls
all the other coaches break down what
you're doing and totally steal
what it is that works um
indianapolis colts uh see uh in motogp
right now there's an insane amount of
young talent coming through the lower
ranks
uh fabio that's uh cuatro was 19 when he
entered the top class
he won the junior world championship the
class below moto
2 in moto 3 twice in a row at age 13.
oh that'd be [ __ ] cool to watch can
you watch that anyway we'd love to see
13 year old kids future stars [ __ ]
ripping it up
um you won at age 13 and 14 mark marquez
was one of the youngest world champions
ever
in 2013 at the age of 20.
he won the moto gp thing uh it isn't
that riding at his age is impressive
uh the top isle of man tt riders are 30
40 48 and 51 and that [ __ ] is crazy
what's impressive
is that he's been able to adapt to the
changes in bikes tires and riding styles
over the years while staying competitive
with the younger guys cheers come to
japan sometime and go [ __ ] yourself
i'd love to go to japan and one of my
favorite writers i already forgot his
name
because i'm new to the sport there's a
great japanese writer in motogp
who had an incredible race i think the
first one um
it's always good to see new blood coming
up in the ranks
um yeah japan is definitely definitely
on the list
um i gotta make that happen obviously
when it's
when we go back to the old normal um
anyway all right guys who won't let you
split the check
oh wait there's a great documentary too
out there about
um the year mark uh sorry valentino
rossi
switched from honda to i think he went
to yamaha
or suzuki i think it was yamaha so um
you know he was he was winning and he
was just the [ __ ] and he was writing for
honda
which is like louis hamilton who's the
[ __ ] and he's driving for mercedes
so there's a lot of critics of f1 who
are saying
you know lewis hamilton wouldn't be as
nearly dominant
if he was driving for somebody else
because mercedes is the best
and then it's also like well lewis
hamilton is also the best so mercedes
wouldn't be winning at the same clip
you know and i think both mercedes and
lewis hamilton would obviously agree to
that
right well the the dumb asses at honda
in early uh this is funny after i just
gave a shout out to japan
um i'm not saying they're still dumb
asses but they made a dumb ass move
where i guess valentino rossi was
getting too much [ __ ] credit they
felt and they said hey it's not just the
rider
it's also the bike they made some so
they alluded to something that well
he is driving riding a honda so that
pissed off valentino rossi
and he switched to yamaha and everybody
thought he was nuts because i guess
yamaha
whoever the [ __ ] he switched to wasn't
um
winning [ __ ] and not only did he go over
there and made
immediately made them a winner he won
the championship the very next year
which from what i can tell is unheard of
having not what little i know watching
f1 and watching an amazing
driver like daniel ricardo you know
switch from red bull team to uh who the
[ __ ] is he with now
i figured he was with la he was with
renault last year and this year i think
he switched again
and um
you know it's it's it's literally like
football where if you like one of the
worst things to be
is the top qb prospect in a draft
because you're going to go to some [ __ ]
[ __ ] team
with no offensive line and then people
who knows how good you could have been
if you were maybe the third ranked guy
and you actually went to a competitive
team that had an offensive line with an
older quarterback and they worked you in
you know
and you had a good quarterback coach you
didn't have [ __ ] a new qb coach
every [ __ ] year um
like happens to a lot of people out here
so that really is interesting anyways
all right guys who won't let you split
the check
uh what's up bill love the podcast okay
one thing that i find
extremely annoying is the the guys have
to pay
convention on dates i'm in college and
the guys i date are in college so i know
that neither of us
having that much money neither one of us
had that much money to spare it seems
kind of [ __ ] up to me that being in a
relationship is like a money-saving tool
for women
and a huge financial burden for men
uh yeah
i would say that i think it was that way
back in the day because women weren't
allowed to work
and then also once you married a guy
like he could [ __ ]
lord over you when you were like his
property
so to you could even vote i mean to try
and balance it out somehow as you had to
go out and go buy you
buy the sarsaparillas um anyway some
guys are animate
adamant about paying for dates i always
was even when you're sincerely
sincerely offering to split parentheses
not some fake
oh my god no you don't have to do that
[ __ ]
all right this is like the coolest chick
ever she wants to pay she's owning up to
the fact that chicks do [ __ ] like that
all right which this is what i wish
happened in politics
so they wouldn't be screaming and
yelling where you could just be like uh
hey you know oh you know obama [ __ ]
drone bomb some weddings and uh you know
he kind of blew the oil companies
okay i can definitely give you that you
know having said that you know this guy
trump's a little out of line here
um you know then you could actually
maybe have a [ __ ] conversation
instead of screaming at some old lady
because she's not wearing a [ __ ] mask
she's going to be dead so just leave her
alone
uh anyways which also puts me in a weird
spot because it feels like
since they bought me bought my meal now
i owe them sex
yes like prostitution but with
food as an uh intermediate step
all that considered what do you say to a
dude
to actually convince him to let you pay
for yourself
um
i don't know what you say because that's
a weird thing that's got to be a weird
thing for a woman where a guy
insists to pay because then you got to
be sitting there going like all right
what do i have on my hands here
do i have an old school gentleman who's
gonna take his coat off and let me step
on it as he walks over a mud puddle
whatever the [ __ ] that is
um or do i have somebody that's gonna be
shoving that dick in my face
because they paid for my [ __ ] uh
steamed spinach here
that's a hell of a thing hey that's see
this is why i wish more women wrote in
on this [ __ ] podcast
well bill maybe if you didn't trash them
every 10 seconds they'd they'd [ __ ]
listen to this [ __ ] uh fair enough
um yeah cause that's interesting that
then you you're gonna be sitting there
being like
okay i'll let you pay for this but you
know that doesn't mean you know
you can take old hank out in [ __ ] 20
minutes when we're back and you prius
um yeah i i just i would tell you this
at this point um uh
the way things are now i would be
terrified as a young
guy out there as far as just like all
right
you know you i'll tell you this to all
the young guys out there if you even get
a hint of vindictiveness or craziness
you gotta you gotta just [ __ ] walk
away like de niro and heat you just
gotta stand up and just [ __ ]
you just [ __ ] walk um
um you know i don't know and then women
i don't know you gotta come up with some
sort of [ __ ] uh
there's got to be there's got to be some
sort of well that doesn't really work if
the guy's a monster
i don't know there's really no solution
because human beings
male and female are just inherently
[ __ ] flood
um i will say to women out there young
women out there that are dating and all
that [ __ ] you know there's plenty of
[ __ ]
dojos out there where you could learn
some [ __ ] grappling and jujitsu
i mean that's my thing i really think
every [ __ ] woman on should
learn how to do that [ __ ] and then they
probably abuse that power too but you
know whatever
i'm just saying like he could [ __ ]
you know when somebody is gonna sexually
assault you they gotta get in close
all right so if you're good at fighting
on your back and you can put that person
in an arm bar
and there's no ref to tap out you
[ __ ] blow out his elbow
that's it nothing kills a hard on like a
broken [ __ ] arm
or just put them in a triangle
i mean i gotta tell you i would think
no matter how much a guy outweighed you
once you i mean i did that
you know what i shouldn't say that i i
should ask rogan this but like
at what level belt
okay does weight class not matter if the
other person
has no grappling skills whatsoever has
no idea like oh [ __ ]
they just did that which means in
another half a second i'm gonna be
in a triangle or an arm bar unless i do
this
i just think that would put you at like
a tremendous tremendous [ __ ]
advantage
um that's something i really want to do
uh
you know with my kids i hope my uh
i hope that you know this [ __ ] this
thing ends soon and you can just
teach your kids how to you know defend
themselves
against you know psychos in life
and then you just teach him like never
abuse this power and all that [ __ ] which
i think is part of the dojo's
responsibility down there but i would
definitely say that okay
now you know how to choke people out
just go [ __ ] walk around choking
people out
um that's another thing too what if you
knew your kid was a psycho do you then
[ __ ] let him
learn how to do that can't have some
cobra kai kid
jesus it's a [ __ ] quagmire all right
father-in-law
offers car uh
dear billys are us congrats on baby
number two thank you
um he is amazing by the way he is
amazing in watching my daughter interact
with them is just one of the coolest
things
ever she's head over heels for him it's
so awesome
uh anyways i'm 30 years old and just
married the woman of my dreams
congratulations
she loves the outdoors is draw a drop
dead 10
and is in residency to become a surgeon
to boot
dude you [ __ ] hit the lottery i work
in the non-profit sector
and and loved it but was unfortunately
laid off due to kovitz i already hear
that
i haven't owned a car for ages because i
live in a
pnw city with great public
transportation what is a pnw
city what in the [ __ ] is that mean that
like i'm supposed to know that
pnw
meaning says pnw serial killers
oh specific northwest that's hilarious
that i just looked up pnw and
immediately said [ __ ]
serial killers all right pacific
northwest city with great public
transportation
and protected bike lanes don't worry i'm
a biker who stops at stop signs and i
don't wear that silly spandex [ __ ]
dude i love a bike lane i wish they
actually had them here in la instead of
spray painting bicycles
on the street um and like there's your
bike lane
new york city has some great bike lanes
where you're on the other side of parked
cars i mean it's [ __ ] amazing
jersey barriers and all that [ __ ]
anyways my new father-in-law
reached out and has offered his 2002
lexus with 130 000 miles on it
for just below kelly blue book value
it's a good deal but i worry he might
hold it over my head in some strange way
we haven't always gotten along for a few
reasons
he's an [ __ ] he talks down to my wife
he believes if you aren't furthering
science you're not worth
really working do i buy it [ __ ] no
thanks and i hope the family is doing
well no [ __ ] this guy if what you're
saying about this guy
he's an [ __ ] he talks down to my wife
no [ __ ] this guy
for all you know this this is the type
of guy if what you're saying about him
is true there's something wrong with the
car
you know and i had a buddy of mine i
remember a long time ago way back in the
[ __ ] day
a buddy of mine when i was a kid uh he
bought a bmw
off a doctor and we were kids man when i
say kids we were still
you know teens early 20s 20s and
he sold it to my buddy and we were
driving home
i saw this blue smoke coming out the a
couple times out of the back
i was like all right it's burning a
little oil whatever um
and then all of a sudden like it just
started sitting weird in the back
and uh finally a buddy of eyes knew
about cars he put it up on the [ __ ]
the lift there and they saw that it had
been in a major
[ __ ] accident and the frame had been
bent and this guy didn't disclose any of
that
so the fact that this guy is a scientist
um
you know and you know it's in defense of
him in this time if you aren't
furthering science as far as working on
a cure covid
i mean it's probably the most important
work right now as far as the world
economy goes but
i would not do that i wouldn't do it i
if you know if you got money to buy a
used car i would buy something else
somewhere else
um yeah yeah that's definitely
[ __ ] it you know you don't want that
guy getting in any clothes you got to
you got to keep a guy like that
at at arm's distance i really believe
that you you're cordial
you have to respect that that is the the
father of the woman that you're gonna
marry and all of this [ __ ] or that you
married or whatever
um you know so you always got to be
respectful
hello goodbye but you don't got to let
them in um all right worried about
college
okay hey bill i love the mmp
and i've watched your conan appearances
at least a million times oh thank you
conan's the best
uh i'm a 17 year old girl and i'll be a
junior at the university of florida all
right go gators by the end of 2020
go gators she writes um i took a ton of
advanced lesson classes in high school
and now i'm
three years ahead
what i'm 17 year old girl i'll be a
junior she's crushing it
at first i thought this was great the
faster i start school the faster i
finish right
i didn't want to waste my entire youth
slaving over textbooks
my issue is that i've been so focused on
academics that i lost out on a lot of
the experiences my friends were having
in high school
i didn't go to parties prom homecoming
football games or even my graduation
ceremony
i'll stress that this wasn't because of
my parents i'm just insanely introverted
and none of these things
seemed appealing well i can relate
because i didn't go to most of those
things either
now i'm basically a socially awkward
weirdo and i'm worried i'll be
50 uh before i even have my first kiss
everyone says college is the best time
of their life so how do i put myself out
there so i
that i can make some friends and maybe
even find a special
fella ah that's adorable thanks and i
think it's pretty mean that people are
always telling you to go [ __ ] yourself
look at you you got a good heart you're
motivated
i'll tell you this right now you're a
catch and a half all right
so any guy is going to be lucky to be
with you
so i was totally introverted you just
have to like
you got to forgive yourself and not beat
yourself up that you're introverted and
that you're shy
so just to start putting yourself out
there baby steps
you know what about bob just baby steps
your way out there
and gradually you know open up you know
if you don't speak up in class
just say all right i'm going to answer
one question today and i'm going to get
over that
and i mean that's how i did it now i
baby-stepped my way into being a
comedian i started any opportunity i had
to take a public prof any any class that
i knew i was not to stand up and speak
in front of the class i would do it
and um once i made that
decision
um i started to have
you know i allowed myself to be not good
at it i allowed myself
to be embarrassed get dry mouth and all
of that [ __ ] stuff
once i was just like okay all this
stuff's going to happen and all of this
stuff is normal because of the way i'm
wired
i just need to to move the ball an inch
in the direction i want to go every day
right
and once i did that i can't
i grew by leaps and bounds as far as
like my confidence so this is something
that
is um is a great thing
that you can work on and it's totally
fixable and then also
uh just start going to some florida
gator games you know i heard the sec
might
have some games this year just go to the
games
um put it out there that you want to go
to the games but you need a crew to go
with
you'll fall in with some people now
here's the thing considering you've been
introverted and all that i'm a little
worried that you're gonna fall in
you know with some you know nah i'm not
worried you know what you're gonna
here's the thing just go with your gut
when it comes with friends
all right if you're feeling that you the
people you're with are cool
and they're good people and you're
clicking with them continue to hang out
with them
if if they're not don't be afraid to
[ __ ] move on
um it's no different than being in a
relationship boyfriend girlfriend with
somebody you know
it's you just gotta listen to your gut
so there you go so congratulations
you'll be fine
um all right rambo helicopter
bill with your knowledge and
understanding of helicopters
yeah pretty limited uh what's your take
on helicopter scenes in
rambos and the rambos well i always
loved them obviously
um this is what i'll say about
not specifically rambo i'll just say in
general in movies
is when somebody's getting chased
and then they run over and just start
they start up a helicopter like it's a
[ __ ] car
and then they just drive away um
that's the [ __ ] most hilarious thing
especially
if it's like a turbine engine like a jet
engine
like you know there's a whole startup
procedure that i've what you should
check it out
look up uh a star 350 startup procedure
and there's a thing when you go to start
it up where the engine is heating up
and you it gets up to a certain
temperature
like 700 degrees and then you have to
back it down or something
like that roll down the throttle uh for
a few seconds before rolling it back up
or you could actually
burn down the [ __ ] helicopter you
could actually have a fire
because of what's going on in the
background um so whenever i watch
one of these movies and somebody gets
and even if you fly what i fly
it's there's a whole startup procedure
especially if the [ __ ] engine is
is like ice cold and um
you know you got to let the belts roll
out you got to let you know you roll up
the power they got attention the
the clutch light has to come out there's
a whole startup percent i mean you can
just you can [ __ ] do it
i guess you could just do it it's not
good for the engine
or anything else and i would be nervous
about that but i guess you know if
my option was getting eaten by [ __ ]
zombies
um but even then it takes
a little bit for it to roll up to
[ __ ] speed
that that's my only issue about it and
then also whenever they shoot out the
[ __ ] tail rotor and then the person
just spins and spins and spins and spins
and spins
you know any helicopter pilot unless
they're brand new the second you start
spinning is you you roll down
to the detent is what they call it so
then it's basically like putting it in
neutral
so now what's keeping the main rotor
turning is the ship
falling rather than uh the torque of the
engine
so whatever you've rolled down to
neutral so neither one of those
the the um the tail rotor not working
now
and the main rotor is still spinning
you're not dealing with the uh the
engine turning that anymore so there's
no torque wanting to turn the the ship
in the opposite direction that the main
road is turning jesus christ
so yeah you would roll down and then
with your pedals what you had left from
the oh what if they shut
wait no they shot it out so then you
don't have that maybe you would i don't
know i've never had my tail rotors shot
out
um so anyway
it's just you know you know what i
talked long enough that you ended up
learning how
what little i know about [ __ ]
helicopters i know more than the average
person but i don't know [ __ ]
and that is a great way to go in life
just know you don't know [ __ ] because
then you'll be open
to learn new [ __ ] by the way uh mrs
jones was written by a guy
named uh was performed i should say by
billy paul
um and i actually went down a rabbit
hole listen to that guy
and i learned about some other singers
that i had never heard of
like if you google billy paul
he ends up he talks about the um singers
that he was
influenced by and what's really cool is
it's really a lot of female singers
because he feels that they did more with
their voices which i thought was
really interesting and then he brought
up this guy
uh [ __ ] where the hell is he
let's see here nina simone johnny mathis
the eldest style
silkiness um and then there's a guy
jessie belvin
said one of my favorites they used to
call him mr easy
jesse belvin and this guy
helped write earth angel and
unfortunately he did a show in arkansas
he was
died when he was 27 got into a head-on
uh
collision in a car and back then you
know those cars were just you know the
engine just went right into your [ __ ]
chest
uh had a head-on collision and died
unfortunately at 27
super talented kid um he did a
a mixed race show him and another i
think
uh african-american act and these
old racist white dudes showed up yelled
a bunch of [ __ ] at the stage which you
know was the n-word and a bunch of other
ugly [ __ ] and then were kept pleading
with the white kids to get up and leave
and um there's a theory that he had his
tires slashed
and that's what caused the accident and
if that's [ __ ] true man
what kind of a [ __ ] human being
could do that to somebody
like and feel no guilt about it and at
the end of their life
you know if you have believe have any
sort of belief in any sort of a high
power
not think that you're going [ __ ]
directly to hell for that one
um [ __ ] brutal so
i don't know i got to tell you i wish i
was better at writing scripts because
to me that's like there's a [ __ ]
movie and a half there
like what happened like no no
investigation just
i don't know how the [ __ ] did they
figure out all these years later or did
people know back then that it was
possibly
tires were slashed i don't know there's
been something to possibly look up jesse
belvin j-e-s-s-e-b-e-l-v-i-n
um all right that's the podcast
everybody thank you so much
for listening uh it's so great that
sports are back
and i'm hearing this news that they're
able to test get test results quicker i
think that that's going to be our way
out of it just it's going to be
testing and um
eventually the quicker you can test
people and the more inexpensive it is
the quicker you'll be able to figure out
who has it who doesn't in your
quarantine and i think we're gonna get
out of this stuff all right and if that
you know
don't yell at people who don't aren't
wearing [ __ ] masks
i mean i understand getting them out of
stores i get that at this point and i
understand why people are yelling
because
financially everybody's [ __ ] hurting
at this point um
but screaming at them is not gonna it's
not gonna help i mean look at me i tried
to [ __ ] make fun of him and i
i never got more negative [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my life
uh i will say to people who don't think
he should be wearing a mask to maybe
watch some international sports and
you'll see that everybody is wearing
masks
and so you don't think that it's a
conspiracy against your guy
which i understand why you would think
that because he has been under attack
the entire [ __ ] time as all
presidents have been
since uh bill clinton you're just under
attack the entire time you're trying to
run the country which is not [ __ ]
helping us out
all right but anyways that's it that's
the [ __ ] podcast
uh thank you for listening go [ __ ]
yourselves and uh
i'll check in on ya on thursday see
you